i think it's so important for people to
remember that they're the creators of
their lives instead of the victim of
their lives right so the victim is
saying i'm feeling this way because that
person or that circumstance or i don't
have any money is causing me to feel
this way that's my relationship with
money what that really means is i'm
using
my lack to reaffirm my dependency my
addiction my conditioning that's my
relationship with money is that i put my
attention on money because i don't have
it so the relationship with money is of
course built on lack and so when they
don't have it they feel bad and what
they're really saying is my outer
environment my reality is actually
controlling the way i feel the way i
think so louise why are you in a good
mood today things are going good why in
a bad mood things are going bad today so
this unconscious program victimization
is saying that we're allowing our
environment to influence the way we feel
the way we think isn't that what
victimization is and the stronger the
emotion we have to our lack the more we
put our attention on the fact we don't
have it right so then the person has
forgotten that they're creating reality
because what they're creating is lack
and they're creating more of it and then
they try harder and they force her when
they come they're more exhausted and
their body's tired and they're breaking
down right so the experiment then is
let's try it another way let's create
from the field instead of from matter
get a coherent heart get a coherent
brain relax in the heart and energy
moves right in the brain we've measured
this thousand times and all of a sudden
the person moves into these beautiful
elegant brainwave states where they're
super creative right so the longer
you're conscious of that energy the more
you draw that future to you
want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you you've got michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and learn
the mindset shifts you can make to get
what you want
enjoy what does the synchronicity mean
it means whatever you're doing inside of
you is producing that effect outside of
you pay attention to what you did
keep going again so generate a little
bit more abundance just do it for an
experiment now when the synchronicity
happens do you think you feel suffering
or do you think you feel a little
excitement you feel inspired right so
then that synchronicity is saying
use this energy use this feeling it
should be easier for you to feel this
now and go back and do it again
keep the experiment going
and here comes the promotion here comes
the here comes the email here comes the
person you meet at the right time right
well we have something happening here
and then that that becomes the momentum
right
so then
we generate abundance that's that's how
we do it and the relationships can just
happen
by accident we generate we generate
abundance right so then if you have an
hour meditation where you're tuning into
your abundant future
but then you're spending the other 15
hours a day in lack don't expect
anything to change you defaulted
you're back to the old energy and if you
say it's that person or that
circumstance or that bank account i'm
going to say you're back to the
unconscious program of being a victim
right so then so then
so then let's go a step further
if your personality creates your
personal reality and it does and your
personality is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel
then the present personality who's
listening to this podcast has created
the present personal reality called
their life nothing big there which means
if you want to change your personal
reality
you're going to have to change your
personality right nothing changes
in your life until you change shift
number two is dream with the lid off
with mel robbins
give yourself permission
to dream with the lid off
this is really important and the reason
why this is important is because i
guarantee you
that right now you are not even allowing
yourself
to fully
dream or
think about or set goals that are truly
aligned with what you deeply want in
your heart
that you aren't even able to manifest
properly because you're not even honest
with yourself about what you actually
want this is a really common thing
because you're allowing yourself
self-doubt you are allowing your fears
your anxiety your insecurity you're
allowing where you are to dictate and
limit where you want to go and so step
one super important you must allow
yourself
give yourself permission to start
dreaming with the lid off now the
scientific reason why this is so
important is because you have a filter
in your brain called the reticular
activity system i write about the ras
for short the reticular activity system
extensively in the high five habit
the ras is a filter in your mind and you
can
do simple things that change the
structure of that filter in fact the
filter in your mind the res is always
changing so one thing that you can do
in order to teach yourself how to dream
with the lid off is to adopt a simple
habit every single morning i do a very
simple thing i write down five things
that i want
that's it
when i start my day after i get up on
the alarm rings i make my bed i pull on
my exercise clothes i set an intention i
high-five myself in the mirror i then go
out into the kitchen i crack open my
high five journal and then inside the
journal there are prompts that walk me
through the steps of visualizing and the
first prompt is dream with the lid off
set your spirit free write down five
things every morning that you want and
this is important because when you get
what you want out of your head
and you physically put them on a piece
of paper research shows that you're 42
more likely to achieve those goals
simply by writing them down that's
pretty cool
secondly your mind is paying attention
and when you take deliberate action and
you write down what you want you are
signaling to your brain
that you
deserve to have these things you are
signaling to your brain that you do want
those things you're not just going to
think about them these are things that
matter to you and that helps train your
mind to allow you to let the desires
flow through you because right now
you're not manifesting properly because
you're not even allowing yourself to
dream with the lid off so that's step
number one you're going to start writing
down five things that you want every
single morning as a way to train your
mind to let you dream freely also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video i've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the lessons learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there shift number three is change your
beliefs with john assaraf at the end of
your day or week do you ever find
yourself
worried or frustrated because no matter
how much effort you put in to work and
no matter how hard you work your
financial situation
and your financial future may never seem
to be improving you might be finding
yourself living paycheck to paycheck
right now with not a lot of breathing
room and i would imagine no
discretionary income or even time to
spend on the little things that really
would make your life more enjoyable
well what i can share with you is you're
not alone that's number one and in most
cases
the real problem
is not your current circumstances
what the real problem is that most
people repeat the same
patterns of thought
and behaviors over and over again
and that is the cause
of what more of the same results but
they are looking for different results
and so today i'm going to show you how
to break that pattern break that cycle
now you see when you think of your
results your results are effects and so
the question is effects of what
and the answer is your results are all
effects of what you believe to be true
about yourself what you believe to be
true that is possible
and it also comes down to what are your
daily habits now
if you think about what you believe and
if you think about your habits that is
what is causing the effect that you may
not like right now and so a simple
logical thing to do would be to
understand that if i could change my
beliefs about what was possible and what
was possible for me specifically and i
could create more empowering habits
then my result will change
and what i love to focus on having done
an enormous amount of brain research
over the last 10 years
is something called your inner game
and your inner game
is comprised of obviously your beliefs
your attitude your perceptions how you
see the world
and your inner game is also comprised of
what causes you to take action
and so let me share just a little story
with you that may help you understand
what i mean about two years ago i was at
a seminar and when i got off the stage
this woman started walking towards me
and i could see she was somewhere in her
you know 50s maybe early 60s she looked
nice she was a vibrant woman she was
walking right towards me and i saw tears
streaming down her eyes
and when she got through the crowd
for a moment i thought that maybe there
was something wrong but she actually had
tears of joy in her eyes
and when i met her her name was joanie
sanderson and this was in perth
australia
and she came up to me she said thank you
so much and i go well for what she says
well
about a year ago i heard you speak about
beliefs
and habits and mastering my emotions and
really working on my self-worth
and she said to me that she was a
caregiver and that she loved helping
families who needed
extra assistance for their aging parents
or for their children who may need some
additional help in the home so she was a
wonderful caregiver but she was living
on a widow's pension of about 12 000
aussie dollars a year
and so she really didn't have enough
money to be able to take the care of her
grandkids that she wanted to to be able
to take her children on a vacation and
so i shared with her why do you think
that you're only earning twelve thousand
dollars a year and she said i don't know
and when i shared with her that she
possibly believed that that's what she
was worth
and she said to me well i think i'm
worth more i said well you might be able
to declare that you're worth more but if
at a deeper level
of your brain
you have this feeling that maybe you're
not smart enough or not good enough or
not worthy enough that is what is going
to drive your behavior
and so what i helped joanie do
prior to her coming to me and being in
gratitude was i helped her recognize
that beliefs drive behavior beliefs
drive emotions
habits drive behavior and in order to
change your results living paycheck to
paycheck being stressed out worrying
about your future or even your present
circumstances right now
why not focus on working on the neural
patterns the beliefs and habits that are
nothing more than patterns in the brain
that drive 96 to 98 of your behavior and
so she started to work on what i call a
belief and habit modification program
and while she did this she started to
see herself in a different light she
started to feel more confident more
certain and more empowered and what i
can share with you
is she at that moment told me that she
went from making twelve thousand dollars
a year as a widow's from a widow's
pension and living paycheck to paycheck
to being able to charge for her services
as she was making 75 000
a year
shift number four is activate your
imagination with marie forleo there's a
prompt in here that i have used so many
times in my life and so many times in my
business that has transformed everything
in a business context it's led to like
multi-million ideas and in a life
context oh my goodness i can't even tell
you how many things that's helped me
shift and it all comes back to tapping
into that wisdom that i already have in
my heart that i wasn't really aware of
so what you're going to need is a
journal or just a notebook or a piece of
paper and i want you to give yourself at
least 15 to 20 minutes of uninterrupted
time with no cell phones around no
things ringing or dinging no televisions
no nothing i just need you to put
yourself in a place where it can be kind
of quiet where you're really comfortable
maybe you have a little cup of tea or
cup of coffee or something stronger if
that's what you're into whatever floats
your boat and you're going to use this
sentence stem to start to unearth what
ellen might really want to focus on in
this next chapter of her life so the
sentence stem goes like this
wouldn't it be cool if dot dot dot so i
want you to write down on the paper
wouldn't it be cool if and then whatever
springs up in your mind and your heart i
just want you to write it down so
wouldn't it be cool if i lived in hawaii
wouldn't it be cool if i could solve
world hunger wouldn't it be cool if i
had platinum blonde hair i don't know
i'm just making stuff up off the top of
my head but what this exercise does is
it starts activating your imagination it
starts dusting off that ability you have
to dream that i suspect may have been
put on the back burner for so many years
because you've been focused on so many
other people because you're so
responsible and you're so loving and
you're such a good person but now my
friend ellen now is the time for you to
rediscover what's in your heart and what
would really be cool for you to focus on
in this next chapter and i promise you
if you play with this prompt wouldn't it
be cool if and you let yourself dream
without editing without squashing
something down because you feel like oh
that's impossible that could never
happen no we don't do that in
brainstorming we let everything down on
the page i promise you you will start to
unearth something that's going to make
you go ah
that feels amazing could i really do
that could i really be that could i
really pursue that and you're going to
get like little tinglies
arms will stay at you the arm hair will
stand up all that kind of good stuff but
it will only happen if you give yourself
this ability to play with this prompt
and do it until you can't write anymore
and shift number five the last one
before some very special bonus clips is
keep the promises you make to yourself
with ed mylett i've been getting asked
lately about the struggles people are
going through with self-doubt not
believing in themselves negative
thoughts about themselves and i believe
the solution to self-doubt is to build
something bigger than that doubt which
is to build our self-confidence and one
thing to know about the fact that you
doubt yourself is one i struggle with it
as well one of the reasons i've had to
go learn to build all these tools for
myself is because in my life my baseball
career my academic career my business
career my speaking career
i've been riddled with self-doubt that
creeps up all the time in our lives am i
enough am i good enough you weren't born
doubting you weren't born discouraged
you weren't born thinking negative
things about yourself those were
thoughts that were placed in you
and given to you by an external source
at some time in your life it could even
be our parents
don't do that be quiet sit down be a
good boy be a good girl maybe it was
criticism you received as a as a little
one that you may not even remember to
this day the process of building
self-confidence is actually very easy
believe it or not self-confidence is
self-trust self-confidence is building a
reputation with yourself that you keep
your word to you that you keep the
promises you make to you when i meet
somebody who has a ton of
self-confidence i don't look at that as
somebody with a big ego there's a
difference somebody with self-confidence
has a reputation with themselves that i
do the things i say i'm going to do
that's where self-confidence comes from
when i meet someone who's not
self-confident i know this is someone
who has consistently made promises to
themselves they've not kept they've
started a diet and done it for a while
but not kept it they've made a
commitment and goals to go make a
certain amount of money in business and
they started down the road but then they
didn't deliver on it long term to get up
at a certain time in the morning and
then they don't do it and so they have a
process and a habit in their life more
often than not of not keeping the
promises they don't make to other people
they don't keep the promises they make
to themselves and so the cool thing is
self-confidence is an internal game you
do not need external accolades external
admiration in order to build
self-confidence you don't need any of
those external forces it's all done
internally you control this and you
control this by beginning today to keep
the promises you make to yourself and
you have to stack the deck in your favor
stack the game so you win it's not good
enough just to keep the promises you
make to yourself you must acknowledge it
when you do it to you to give yourself
credit to create confidence momentum is
what i call it so whether that's setting
the deck where you're going to get up a
little bit earlier you're going to make
a certain amount of phone calls you
misses a certain amount of appointments
you're going to eat a certain amount of
calories in your fitness you're going to
spend a certain amount of time with your
children or your parents and you begin
to do these things you say you're going
to do you say simple things like i'm
going to lay out my clothes the night
before i go to bed every night
before i go to sleep so when i wake up
that decision is made for me and believe
it or not the fact that you just do
something that simple that you then
deliver on begins to build confidence
you say i'm going to stretch in the
morning when i get up and you do it all
of a sudden i'm not going to check my
phone for 30 minutes all these habits i
teach when you just begin to do the
things you tell yourself you're going to
do you begin to build self-confidence
which is this reputation with yourself
so ask yourself a question right now
what is one thing right now one promise
i can make to myself that i'm going to
begin to keep starting this minute
and begin to do it it could be how often
i'm going to pick up a book and read it
but you begin to stack things you commit
to do and then you deliver on them and
you acknowledge them to yourself you're
in the process of building
self-confidence why is that so important
of all the athletes i coach when my
athletes are performing at their peak
level they're at their highest
self-confidence level in fact i love
when i watch some of the athletes i
coach get interviewed and they kind of
do this aw shucks humble routine in
their post-game interviews yeah you know
just part of the team you know i got a
lot i could have done a lot better today
but inside i know these people are
incredibly self-confident people any of
you athletes listening to this you know
this the great athletes you know have
incredible amounts of self-confidence
you have to believe in you when it's a
battle when you're a hitter against a
pitcher or when you're a quarterback
against a defense or you're a defenseman
in the nhl against their best offensive
player or you're a golfer and you have
to make a nine foot putt to win a
tournament right you better have
self-confidence in fact the separator
more often than not at the highest level
in sports is not they're a better
shooter or a better putter or throw the
ball a little bit faster because
everybody throws hard in the major
leagues nowadays it seems right that
separators their self-confidence
it's true in being a parent it's true in
being a business person it's true in
every area of our life the separator at
the top levels is self-confidence
you have no idea what you're capable of
you have no idea you have no idea the
person you could be to think you could
accomplish the things you can do the
people you can serve you've no idea
that's why i don't like 10-year goals
10-year goals think about who you used
to be 10 years ago you know could that
person accurately with any with any
degree of certainty predict where you
could be right now no like if you're
growing and you're learning you're
improving and you're expanding
you're invested in yourself there's no
way that you know where you're going to
be in one year let alone five years or
ten years you have no idea what you're
capable of
and so it comes down to questioning
everything
the question what you can and can't do
you know we're told the story growing up
of what you should do and we're told
everything right you're told
when to show up and where to go and what
to wear and what to eat and what at what
age you should get married and what kind
of crew you should go into right we're
told we should do all these things
you're told you're like who you know
nobody ever thought to ask us what we
want for our lives and you may not even
know and that's okay like you may know
where you want to go next but you may
not ultimately know the final
destination it's awesome
you know i think if you know the final
destination you're thinking small apart
from having a mission you know the
mission the purpose why do you do what
you do i want to solve the world's
biggest problem people don't believe in
themselves enough that's what i'm
chasing down every day
do i know where i'm going to be in a
year no
am i still making videos probably but
who knows i question everything i want
to i want people to believe themselves
more what's the best way to do that
right now it's through youtube
but i think a lot of times people have
too certain of a plan
and then they end up
playing small because there's nothing
wrong with having goals and plans but
sometimes you need to jump off that if
you have a 10-year goal
quite often you need to jump off that
goal two years in because something
better has come along that actually
better serves who you are right now
because the goal you set was for who you
used to be
you know have you felt that
and so i'm here at a genius network and
this is a group of super successful
entrepreneurs that meets once a month
and masterminds and talk about their
business and um pay a lot of money to be
a part of something like this and
every time i'm around people who are who
are having a high degree of success
i always try to have them pick me apart
so when we when we do there's an
exercise called hot seats where you go
around the table and you
basically share what your biggest
what you think your biggest problem is
and whenever it gets to my turn
i just want people to ask me questions
because
the biggest problem is you don't know
what your biggest problem is
right your biggest problem is you don't
know what your biggest problem is if you
knew what your biggest problem was you
can go and solve it
for for entrepreneurs for ambitious
people for you've got goals like
you don't know what the real problem is
the problem you think you have
is a problem you know the problem you
think you have yes very much is a
problem but there's a deeper problem
underneath it that you're missing
that i'm missing
so this is where questioning everything
becomes important my default has become
instead of pretending like i know
everything and i know all my problems
that i don't know anything and
ask me questions
and in the process
of asking me questions and learning
about me maybe you come with some
insight that i've never seen before
everybody has their own way of
processing
um
giving advice you know so i'm around
people here everybody here has a seven
or eight figure nine figure business
some people here have sold their
businesses
for nine figures
crazy
awesome
and so
they have their own way of
processing things and asking questions
and
breaking somebody down
so instead of me coming in with
the question
and having them trying to fit into my
box i'd rather fit into theirs
because in trying to understand how they
process
things it'll probably make me stretch
and grow and learn
and i'm probably going to get a better
result because they're going to see
something that i don't see
and so
in the process of questioning everything
when people can break you down and
you're open to it
right because we're we hold on to our
identity like no that's not gonna work
for me
you know even oh i gotta be
i am allergic to bees
maybe i should question that
i don't feel like questioning that today
though
do not want to get stung by a bee i once
got stung by a bee and uh
only time in my life i've been sung by a
bee and it i was on the floor and my my
back just
swelled up from the bee sting
um
anyway
maybe question everything except these
things how about that
uh there's been times when people give
me advice and it made sense and it
really fit
and sometimes when it didn't
and and even if it doesn't make sense
what i'll default in my head to saying
is this is either nothing like the
person didn't read me correctly or it's
the whole thing
think about if you're really opposed to
somebody's advice or feedback for you if
somebody gives you great advice like oh
wow that's really cool i should go and
do that cool they they they met you
where you were at and you understand it
but there'll be other times when it it
doesn't
feel right
and
it could be that it just wasn't a fit
and they're giving you the wrong advice
or
you're so blind and this is what
gets me excited is maybe i'm so blind
maybe i believe my story so much
that the thing that you're talking about
is actually the whole thing like it's
all i should care about
because figuring out how to solve that
because i'm so tied to my own story that
i'm not questioning enough and coming
back to the b spot hopefully it's gone
i'm not questioning enough
and figuring that out becomes the the
whole unlock
so a quick story on this i did a life
coaching session with garyvee's lead
coach beth hendell and at first i was
shocked he didn't know i didn't know
garyvee had a life coach and so i was
very excited to talk to her and
just like i've been explaining this
video i went through her process like
how do you ask questions what do you
want to know about me i don't want it to
be if this is a coaching session just
treat me as a
treat me as a client treat me as
somebody who you're going to coach what
do you need to know from my story and
how i act and i'm going to i'm going to
be as open as honest as possible
and what it led to was
a lot of the stuff she was saying
um was great
but my single biggest insight and
takeaway was this and i'm practicing
this every single day now
the one takeaway that has honestly
changed my life
historically i've been the person who
believes in the plan
so what's my plan to get to the next
step like i want to go here what's my
plan what's my plan what's my plan so i
have the belief in the plan and i wake
up every day and i just do the plan
because i believe in the plan
i have some days where i don't believe
in a plan anymore like will this plan
help get me anywhere is this plan still
working like it's not working anymore
and that leads to
some anxiety for me because i believe in
the plan and when the plan doesn't work
what happens
and so what i'll end up doing is making
a new plan
so i have a plan i believe in a plan
until i don't believe in it anymore
causes anxiety come up with a new plan
the following so when creating a new
plan then i have certainty in the plan
again and i'm fine and i'm rocking and
rolling but
there are some days
there are some days when i can't come up
with a new plan the plan i have i don't
believe it anymore and i'm rocking my
brain to come up with a new plan and i
can't come up with a new plan
if i'm the kind of person who believes
in the plane and then i can't come up
with a new plan that's a really
uh stress-inducing anxiety-filled place
to be and it doesn't happen that often
but when it does and i can't come up
with a new plan especially in the moment
well what i would end up telling myself
is great things happen to me
you know what you know what happened
great things happen to you
and i would use it as a self-soothing
mechanism as a coping mechanism
because i didn't want to just stay
locked because locked in that stress and
it would be a downward spiral
like if i believe in the plan and that
the plan is not working and i can't come
with a new plan
then i don't know what to do with my
life and that would create a downward
spiral i've never gone anywhere close to
depression or suicide but that would
lead to some dark that could lead to
some dark places and so the way that i
come out of it is just say great things
will happen to me great things happen to
me they already they always happen to me
great things happen to me and i'll
figure this out
and that gives me the comfort to
move forward into the uncertainty and
then something will come that i will
solve it and what she said was garyvee's
life coach was
what you say to yourself
when you need that
self-soothing
of great things happen to you
needs to be your default state
so instead of believing in the plan as
your default state and only going to
great things happen to you when you are
at the lowest of your low
flip it to the point where great things
happen to you is the default
because that's where you're actually
your best self
and
i really felt that i don't know how to
do it
but even in questioning how do i do it
i just have to believe that great things
happen to me
so
a big part of my routine now is is i
don't know how many times i'll i'll say
that to myself feel that
way things happen to me i'm going to put
it as my new cell phone background
it's a it's a constant reminder even
making his videos another reinforcement
of it um when people ask me what my
goals are
there's been these exercises we've been
doing and genius network here and uh
i just i just keep reminding myself i
don't know i don't have a 10 10-year
goal great things happen to me
it's a constant reminder and i
[Music]
i would i used to live it before this
awareness
i don't know like how many times would i
feel really down and low and
anxiety-filled that i couldn't come up
with a new plan
maybe half of one percent of the time
like really small amounts
and now i'm probably living in great
things happen to me maybe
five percent of the time ten percent of
the time which is a huge jump from half
of one percent but it's still not my
default mode yet
i'm still a believe in the plan guy
that's my ongoing challenge to myself
that's how i'm questioning
it's the willingness to question what
you're doing because what you're doing
right now has gotten you to where you're
at and if you're if you're happy with
where you're at cool but if you want
more you want to create more you want to
serve more you want to bring more you
want to help more you want more
you want to change and you have to
change
and the change starts with not just
questioning everything out there
question everything in here
questioning
what you believe to be true questioning
who you think you are
questioning for sure what you think
you're capable of
because when you can get to the root of
that
amazing things can happen you have to
really begin to
mentally rehearse
like so you ask yourself at the end of
your day i do this every day how'd i do
how'd i do today bro how'd you do did
you do good where'd you fall from grace
what what what was it
that caused you to go unconscious
for the rest of the day like what was
that moment now if you're a student
of life you'll begin to contemplate well
it was that person that said that thing
then i reacted or this i got this email
or things didn't go my way and i started
feeling angry or frustrated or fearful
the next time that happens
how could i evolve my experience now you
may have to search for some answers
of the best model to build or you may
actually have a long contemplation and
start to go god the next time that
happens i think i'm going to do this or
i'm going to do that or i'm going to
plan my behaviors
and the act of closing your eyes
and rehearsing what you're going to do
begins to install the neurological
hardware in your brain to looks like you
already did it now the brain is no
longer a record of the past now it's a
map to the future and if you keep
installing that hardware the hardware
will become a software program which
means you'll just start acting like a
happy person why there's no magic there
you install the circuitry so
that's more important
than the news right it's more important
than answering any email or any text
it's more important than talking about
your past or some dinner
if you can begin to just
think about how you're going to do it
differently
that's the building process
neurologically already so now you have
to get conscious in order to do that and
it takes some time it means you got to
shut your cell phone off you got to
close your door you got to take a break
from everything out there and begin to
practice and so
by experience then
you start noticing oh here it comes here
comes the frustration here comes the
fear
and now we've given people the tools to
be able to self-regulate to create brain
and heart coherence and so you see
people say excuse me one minute i'm just
going to need a minute
it takes some breaths they get back in
they connect to the energy of their
future this is incidental compared to
where they're going so they don't
fall from grace they don't allow their
energy to drop and so
yeah in the beginning
it takes a lot because it takes a lot of
energy and awareness
to stay conscious and not go unconscious
but if you're persistent and you're
determined then you're sincere
you begin to figure it out you begin to
say
i am not going to give my power away to
that person or that circumstance when i
can use it to heal or to create a new
future and so people then
won't excuse themselves and say on a
hard day yesterday i had a fight with my
coworker or my ex or and i don't feel
like doing the work well
that's the time to get back on the horse
yeah because because
it's the it's all of those times that we
self-correct
those are the most valuable moments thus
people who've had profoundly
transcendental experiences where they
we say got lit up they connected and
their brain goes into very very high
coherent states and
super gamma patterns that are way
outside of normal and they have a
transcendental download or connection
that's mystical
they look back at their entire life
they don't want to change one thing in
their past
because it got them to that moment
that's the moment the past no longer
exists now by the same means
they look back at their past
and they see all those tough moments
where they overcame themselves and they
fall in love with that person they don't
look at the good meditations or the
things that went well they look they
know that it was those moments that got
them to this moment
and i think then
that's when they begin to understand
that that all of the hard work
all the effort in who we become makes
no one can take that away from us so
then once we arrive at that level and we
experience whatever the dream is or
whatever we create the next thing is do
it until you fully enjoy it and then
when it gets boring or predictable let's
go again let's do something else here's
the hard truth about getting great
it takes time and dedication
it takes a willingness to accept that
you're not yet good enough it takes the
ability to stare at the places that you
know that you're weak to really look at
those things and not let it affect your
sense of self-esteem and not let it
affect your sense of self-worth so that
you can still get the momentum going but
you have to understand that in the
beginning
we're all terrible
and as henry cartier-bresson said your
first 10 000 photographs are your worst
and so the thing that really makes great
art are the people that continue to push
and the people that continue to work and
face how inadequate they are and really
understand that at the end of the day
greatness is a craft greatness is a
process
greatness
is a habit
greatness is the little things that you
do every day over time going out every
day unafraid of whether or not this is
one of the ten 000 terrible
things that you're gonna do it's being
unafraid to make those mistakes is being
unafraid
that you're not yet great
and as marianne radmaker said
courage doesn't always roar sometimes
courage is the quiet voice at the end of
the day saying
i will try again tomorrow
and that's it
if you want to be great that's what you
have to do you've got to get up again
tomorrow you've got to be willing to
face another day you've got to be
willing to accept that you've got to get
through the bad ideas before you can get
to the good you've got to understand
that you have to start as an apprentice
you have to start as a person going and
getting t and you have to accept that
that's the job that you should be
playing that you should be working for
somebody else you should be looking up
to somebody else's seeing what they can
teach you because what you know
is that you're there to learn what you
know is that you're there to get through
the 10 000 bad photographs that you need
to get through to ultimately achieve
greatness and if you make the
catastrophic error that so
many
make
to try to tell the world that you're
extraordinary today
to try to get the world to follow you
and look up to you and think that you're
something
today
[Music]
because the people that really win are
the ones that invest
today the ones that listen today the
ones that spend every ounce of their
energy
amassing mastery getting better every
day working their asses off to improve
their skill set to relentlessly look at
the things that they're not doing well
to understand that they have to break
themselves down and get rid of all of
their ego before they can really find
greatness
those are the people that we remember
so if you want to be remembered
if you want to achieve real greatness
you just need to have the courage to
show up every day
and take another swing
take another photo
try another task
do something that scares you
and do those little things over and over
and over
until you win i think we're all faced
with great opportunities brilliantly
disguised as impossible situations
and in order like for me personally and
i and after looking through your book
and reading a good portion of it
i mean for me there's there's no school
of ancient wisdom that you need to go to
to be initiated your life is your
initiation if you're paying attention so
we meet challenges in our life from a
certain level of mind right a certain
level of consciousness or
unconsciousness and even einstein said
we have to go to a greater level of
consciousness
than the consciousness that's created
the problem what is consciousness
consciousness is awareness
and awareness means possibilities that
you haven't thought of before
so
we confront problems or challenges in
our life and as a side note
i was having breakfast with a researcher
just last week who's studying what
happens when we perceive a condition in
our environment as a problem how it
weakens the organism they're measuring
this and when a person sees it as a
challenge how they draw energy they
raise the energy of their body back into
order
so
if we said i want to be
wealthy or i want to be healthy
well what you want to be that because
you're not it
so the initiation of going from not it
here to it here you're gonna have to
climb some steps and there's going to be
some blind spots so you try it out and
it doesn't work
well that's because there's a part of
you that's still in a habit there's part
of you that's still unconscious okay so
what is it about myself and that
circumstance
that i am feeling
about that circumstance and that feeling
is causing me to think about it so you
say oh it's impossible they'll never
change i'll hire a hitman i'll hire the
mafia i'll hire an attorney i'll have my
friend's friend to talk to him and
nothing changes right well
you're not you're not separate from that
experience you're involved in it and how
you think and how you feel broadcast
energy into the field so your energy is
the same every day and as long as your
energy is the same nothing's going to
change in your life either and nobody
changes until they change their energy
so then
what piece of knowledge
what piece of information what would
love do what would greatness look like
okay i don't know
all right well certainly somebody in
history has faced this problem
don't get on facebook and say does
anybody have any answers don't get
go look it up and study and read and
learn you'll own it and you'll say wow
that person that was wealthy
they failed 500 times well hell i had
the wrong view of wealth
okay then failure is not a thing i got
to overcome failure well yep just
climbed a step yeah okay i'm reacting to
that circumstance with the same emotion
that emotion is firing the same thoughts
i'm broadcasting the same energy into
the field
if i were facing that circumstance and
situation again with that person that
circumstance what do i learn from that
circumstance how could i do it
differently the next time
find out a solution and rehearse it
install the circuitry so when you get in
the circumstance you're not going to
respond in an automatic habituation yeah
now you're at a greater level of
consciousness now you're looking at
possibilities that you weren't looking
at before because you were unconscious
now
that process of trial and error is so
important in the spiritual path
how many times
do we have to forget before we remember
and then we remember and we forget again
and it takes constantly remembering
until we stop forgetting and when we get
to that point now we're conscious
now there's wisdom and wisdom is the
memory
of the experience without the emotional
charge now you're ready for the new
adventure so then
people draw conclusions and say oh it's
that person that ripped me off as that
person that
now now you don't create your reality
you only create reality when things are
good
well somehow you got to tango through
this somehow your objectivity in not
reacting emotionally
is going to change the energy of how you
address this situation when i was small
mom i was also really undersized so it's
probably one of the reasons i lift
weights i was always the every baseball
pitcher i'm the kid holding the sign in
the front right so i was small and
skinny they used to tease me eddie
spaghetti you know and i'd get bullied
at school and i never retaliated so i
had that mixed with shyness mixed with
chaos in my home which many people can
relate to and i got to tell you that the
shift for me sports was good for me
because it gave me an out that i finally
found something that i was pretty good
at
i think the biggest shift in our lives
the things that makes us the happiest is
that when somebody helps us identify our
natural giftedness
and when i was a little boy i got a
little bit older they pointed out my
speed
so it wasn't my lack of size i was fast
i was the fast kid right i always wanted
to be fast kid and i got confidence in
baseball doing that when i got into
business i said you know you're intense
when someone points out a gift about you
that you also kind of intuitively know
to be true
they're linked to them you're intense
you're passionate you won't get out work
you're relentless i went i am those
things and when someone linked those
gifts to me winning now i believed i
could win that's the other way to change
identity is when someone can link your
giftedness to the victory you'll believe
it not like you're great that's general
that's [ __ ] but it's something you
know specific like for you right now
you wouldn't brag about there's a few
things you know you know what i am good
at these things right i've always been
good at these things it's natural for me
and when someone links that to you
winning like for you for example you're
an unbelievable interviewer you have
this general
you you don't need to be the smartest
person in the room because you probably
are most of the time and so there's a
confident no there's a confidence that
allows you to be present when you
interview me and just listen that's
different than anyone who's interviewed
me before and so that's a natural
giftedness for you which is why there's
a part of you that kind of knows i am
pretty you wouldn't say it but i am
pretty good at this this is a good
program and so the way we change our
identity the way i changed mine was by
getting in touch with what some of my
natural gifts were and then using them
in my career using them in my life that
shifted the weight right off of me
because the weight was i suck i'm shy
i'm small
i have a screwed up family that's the
weight right the lifting off of the
weight is these are some gifts god gave
me or the universe gave me or that at
least i know i have and i can spend my
life using these gifts now i've got hope
now my identity is changing now my life
takes a different direction so if you
take
any event that's occurred in the past if
you just merely think of that event
that's occurred in the past chances are
you're firing off the neural network of
that pattern
right so you can take um
the idea of eating your favorite dessert
what do you think is happening in your
brain when you pretend you're eating
that favorite dessert of yours and your
mouth starts to water and you start to
feel oh that's such a great dessert
that's neurons in your brain firing in
the neurochemistry that is associated
with that memory firing now
let's say
that you have a
disempowering pattern of being
embarrassed or ashamed or ridiculed but
instead of just thinking about the
pattern oh i don't like it as soon as
you think about the pattern
and it has a i'm gonna say a
disempowering or negative emotion
chances are that means that the stress
center in the brain has been activated
that means that your heartbeat's going
to go up that means that your sweat
glands are going to be activated that
means you're going to breathe a little
bit less uh
deeply you're going to be more shallowly
and that is the fear or stress response
now what if
instead of allowing that to continue you
just stopped
and you had this intention
i'm going to dissolve the effectiveness
or the strength of this pattern how do
you do that well first and foremost you
stop you sit
and you start with inner size number one
that actually i guide you through
in the book
all right and inner size number one
is
called take six calm the circuits so you
want to move from your stress and react
system
to your relax and respond system you
have
parasympathetic and sympathetic nervous
systems okay that are triggered within
the body so what happens when you sit
quietly and you take six deep breaths in
through your nose
and out through your mouth like you're
blowing out through a straw when you do
it six times
10 second rhythmic breaths
and you focus
on the air that you're blowing out
through your mouth like you're blowing
out through a straw
that simple inner size
is inner size number one take six calm
the circuits it actually
deactivates the stress
fear embarrassment shame guilt circuit
and in a quiet relaxed state
that same memory does not have the same
power but if you don't do it in that
state you do it in a in a tense
stressful state you're actually
reinforcing that pattern versus thinking
about bringing up that old memory
and doing this repetitively
10 times 20 times 30 times 40 times
until the neurons really don't fire that
strength at that strength level the
majority of our thoughts and feelings
are connected to our sexuality to our
victimization our guilt our suffering
our shame our unworthiness our
self-doubt or our importance our control
our fear our anger our frustration our
hatred our judgment those are those are
the first three hormonal centers in the
body and and those first three centers
have everything to do with survival and
those centers are energy consumers
orgasm digestion
stress
is a lot of energy that we're drawing
from our very vital life force yes a
resource of light and information and
we're turning it into chemistry and
we're literally robbing the body's
energy right so so then living like that
for the short term is okay because the
body can move back to homeostasis it can
restore itself but
when we're overdoing that consistently
then there's no energy for growth and
repair there's because you're living
constantly in survival so
again you can eat all the right food you
can do all the right things but if
you're living in anxiety and fear and
you're viewing your world from the worst
case scenario that could possibly happen
because that's what you do in survival
there's no energy for growth and repair
there's no energy for healing so the
majority of our thoughts
are signaling certain circuits in the
brain that signal another part of the
brain limbic brain to make what's called
a neuropeptide neuropeptides are
chemical messengers that signal hormonal
centers so now you're taking thought
and you're storing it as energy in these
energy centers and and if you're living
in survival why would you open your
heart i mean it's just not a time to
open your heart i mean if you're getting
chased by t-rex
it's not a time to meditate it's not a
time to learn it's not a time to connect
it's not a time to communicate it's not
a time to sit down and go within it's
not a time to be vulnerable it's time to
run fight or hide and so is that why
we're this way i've never asked you this
before is this some
uh i don't i don't think you believe
this but i just want to understand is
this some sort of genetic disposition
that's been passed down to us since
we've been chased by t-rex i think so i
think survival has been very adaptive
yeah like because if you're being chased
by t-rex you don't run up to two t-rex
and say oh cute little dinosaur let me
pet you that's not adaptive the fear is
adaptive you run from the unknown you
run from challenges right so if you're
living in survival there's better
chances of surviving
if you run from the unknown and by the
way when you're living in survival at
the infinite potentials in the quantum
field
you'll select the worst case scenario in
your mind
and you'll begin to emotionally prepare
yourself for the worst case scenario
because you have better chances of
surviving there you go if you prepare
for the worst right so people spend
their whole life yes thinking about the
worst thing and emotionally embracing it
while you take a thought an emotion or
an image and an emotion your branding or
conditioning your body into what anxiety
right into fear so then you keep doing
that over and over again over and over
again your the body becomes the mind of
fear and
whether you think you can control it or
not you're gonna have a panic attack and
the panic attack is the body's saying
you've conditioned me this way try as
you may with your conscious mind and
control it right you programmed it
subconsciously then you start worrying
about the next panic attack and it's
that very anticipation there we go keeps
the person on the hamster wheel it robs
them of all of this energy as well
they're absolutely so so so they don't
believe
in possibility when they're living in
that state because in survival it's not
a time to create all the blood flow is
going to the hind brain and away from
the forebrain there's no there's there's
no physiology really for a person to
begin to create a new future so then so
think about it so then
70 of the time people in the world are
living anticipating the next moment
based on their past moment and so
they're laying reality down moment by
moment with the next known the next
predictable moment and so the hormones
of stress endorse the senses our senses
become heightened when we're under
stress
and we become materialists we narrow our
focus on the danger yes so then you're
focusing on matter you're focusing on
the material world and when you do that
you put all your attention the arousal
of the stress hormones puts all your
attention on your body if you're being
chased by t-rex you better be paying
attention to your body i'm in this
three-year journey of trying to conceive
and
really for a year and a half almost two
years i was like in the low of it really
feeling like okay i'm not good enough my
body isn't working how can i make this
happen how can i make this happen right
and really pushing and controlling and
trying to eat things and
track my ovulation and all that crap
and then about the fall of 2017 i
started to get into more of a
surrendered state and i started
practicing the methods that i teach in
the book of just really
trusting that there
was
a
higher guidance that i believed in for
my whole life and relying on that and
that's when things started to get really
wild and synchronistic and so around the
fall of 2017 i was driving in the
countryside where i lived most of the
time and this is where i do the majority
of my manifesting is just driving in the
car
looking at the foliage listening to my
mantra music and i feel so awesome when
i'm in that position and i'm just so
grateful in the moment and i'm driving
and i'm driving i'm like i feel so
awesome and so grateful that i live in
this country town i have all these
friends and i don't have any cell
service right now and i'm so psyched
about that and no one's bothering me and
i feel good and then all of a sudden i
felt the presence of a baby in the back
seat
and i was like
wow like deeply moved tears started to
roll down my face i felt so moved
and at that point i heard my intuition
say to me
the baby's coming in march
and i was like and it was so loud like
you know when you hear the voice of your
inspiration you're like that's it okay i
believe and so i started saying to
myself over and over like oh my god
march you know i have to conceive at
this time for the baby to come to work i
saw myself getting a little into it like
too into it and hooked into it so i said
okay listen you know what universe i'm
gonna give this over
and if my baby is indeed coming in march
show me a sign
show me lily's to let me know that the
baby's coming in march
and a week later i got a letter in the
mail from a reader and it had this angel
card in it and on the back of it was
this picture of archangel gabriel and
archangel gabriel is typically depicted
holding lilies so i was like yo this is
dope and on the back he wrote i thought
that you needed this i was like thank
you good so here i am march march is
coming march is happening and early
march rolled around and i wasn't
pregnant so i was like what the hell and
not only was i devastated once again
another month has gone by i'm not
pregnant but this time i was like i
thought the universe had my back like i
was getting signs like what what's the
uh what's up
so i walked into my husband's office and
i was just hysterically crying so upset
so defeated
and at some my phone was like on the
desk like right here
and all of a sudden my phone started
playing a song
and the song was just repeating
repeating it so i go like you know when
your phone malfunctions you're like i'm
just gonna turn that off i was like okay
i'm just gonna turn out and then i look
at the phone and i start listening to
the lyrics and the lyrics are way go
lily
way go lily and the guy keeps repeating
way go lily and then i look even further
and i look at the name of the song as
wade go lily and he keeps repeating lily
and i look even further and the album
title is i see the sign
and where was this playing where what
area of your phone this is just my phone
just turned on oh no that's you know
it's spirit working through the
technology and so my phone just turned
on it was an album that i'd never heard
i'd never heard the song before it
wasn't in my spotify and it just began
playing now get this
so i get i april rolls around and i'm
pregnant
but then i did the math and i was like
when did i conceive
i conceived the last day of march
so that
synchronicity you know you hear march
you find your signs you feel super
guided that synchronicity is available
to all of us but it's when it had we
have to get out of that pusher mentality
and out of that controlling behavior to
allow the presence of spirit to work
through us and guide us and or the
universe or whatever you whatever you
call it to be the presence of of of
direction inspiration when the fear
signal has kicked in
all right it's releasing the
neurochemicals like i said epinephrine
cortisol norepinephrine which is
adrenaline
and some of it's good too much of it
will cause you to fight
to freeze
to flee run away or to faint those are
the four
okay possible outcomes for the stress
response or fear response system when it
kicks in so when that switch is turned
on think of it as a light switch that
just turned on in your brain and then
there's a cascade
okay of neurochemicals that causes a
feeling
if you focus on the feeling then you're
going to think about what you feel then
you're going to feel what you think
about you create the self-fulfilling
doom loop of neurochemicals being rushed
in your body and if you do that every
day every week every month over and over
again you've now just set up a doom
loop habit where that fear is going to
drive your thoughts and emotions and
behaviors or lack thereof but what i
want you to do
is recognize the fear
calmly and you do this
as soon as you recognize the fear that
you can bring up on your own you do the
first inner size okay inner size
exercise for your physical body and your
organs inner size for your neuro muscles
all right so
when you feel fear
be in observation of it like the light
comes on in the dash of your car
and then what you do is you take six
deep breaths but here's how you do it
in through your nose
out through your mouth like you're
blowing out of a straw so it goes like
this six breaths 10 seconds each ready
deep rhythmic breaths in up to the lungs
expand the diaphragm so you get the
diaphragm and the lungs expanding
and you breathe out like you're
breathing through a straw so you focus
the energy
out
through the mouth it causes your brain
to actually get
oxygenated
and guess why you want that well when
we're in a state of fear we activate
okay the vagus nerve which constricts
your blood flow it slows down your
heartbeat it causes shallow breathing so
as soon as you
alternate from that fear and stress
response system to the calm
the i'm sorry from the from the stress
and react system to the calm and respond
system
your brain shuts off the fear circuit
and activates
the left prefrontal cortex and when you
can think because blood flows back there
again so if fear is holding you back
there's nothing wrong with fear
but there just
may be um
a lack of skill of knowing when or what
to do does this make sense
so far does this make sense so far so
when you take those six deep rhythmic
breaths
that is what deactivates that stress
response system in the brain and
activates
the relax and respond you want to be in
a responsive state
as much as possible
versus a reactive state i think one of
my first things in failure
is
don't take it more personally than it
actually is and i'll give an example of
that when i was applying to
40 companies that all rejected me before
an interview yeah
all i was getting was an automated
response
saying your application will not go any
further
i can't take that personally because
they didn't meet me in person they
didn't have a
interaction with me they just saw my
name they saw i'd been a monk for three
years
that resume is useless i mean what's
your transferable skills like sitting in
silence and stillness
one wants to hire a monk and so they
rejected you but that's not personal
because they didn't meet me in person
but what if they had me right so that's
the first thing the first step is don't
take all fear failure i'll give an
example me and you
we reach out to countless guests to be
on our podcast we say no all the time
who's saying all the time but if i don't
hear a no from the guest directly
that's not a no like someone's team can
say no someone's assistant can say no
someone's pr team can say no but until
they say no personally it's not a no
okay but when they do say no then that's
a no yeah so then let's move how do you
deal with that type of failure yes so if
i deal with a failure where someone
meets me in person and gets to know jay
you're horrible you suck like i don't
want to deal with a monk ever in my life
yeah i would never go on your show i'm
never listening to you never yeah then
how do you deal with that type of so
i've heard you say this i i've said it a
couple of times and i'm sure it's been
repeated a bunch of times around how i
genuinely believe failure has feedback
and and so for me it's like failure has
the ability
to actually tell you what you need to
improve now not to improve to get their
attention
improving to get the actions that you
want to take yeah the results you want
the results you want and don't make that
result about the person who said no
don't try use failure as a way to prove
someone else wrong because what happens
when we prove others wrong when you
prove others wrong you end up trying to
get validation and approval for them and
now if they're not impressed when you're
right you lose again so you end up
losing twice and you spend all this time
and energy
years maybe to prove something wrong
i've been there many times and then
you're like i felt good for a moment
yeah and then i feel empty again totally
and and so that's the thing about
failure in the second half is you have
to see failure as an improvement if if
i'm completely honest
everyone who rejected me in my life up
until now
has
made me more hungry taught me so much
more about myself and made me up my game
yeah and i think if failure doesn't make
you up your game it's the same as losing
in a sport
right you and you fail and you've lost
games and you've won games on the big
stages you didn't have the skills you
didn't have the teamwork you guys
weren't hungry enough you were never
interested
in enough there's something you were
missing yeah so you go review the game
film you check the stats you see what
could have done better and you try to
improve that for the next game yeah and
i think a lot of people can do that in
life but we're so afraid to like go on
the next game of life like i got
rejected once and it hurts so bad yeah
how do people learn to overcome that
pain of rejection yeah and keep going
yeah you know in sports luckily there's
a season which like you might have 30
basketball games after you lose the
first two you don't say uh i'm just
going to give up the rest of the season
yeah you keep playing yes but in life a
lot of people stop playing yeah why yeah
i think that's great mental training too
i think sports is great mental training
because you have to show up to the next
game even if you lost and you don't feel
bad exactly that you don't feel good
sorry and and one of the things before i
dive into that question one of the
things that you reminded me of was that
the last dance documentary so there's
that season
that michael jordan everyone is
agreement in an agreement that he is one
of the best players to be playing and
they keep losing they didn't make the
fight they didn't make the finals they
lost
and then they realized they need to get
the team and they need to find i think
they're bringing dennis rodman and then
start bringing in all these other
players that strengthen whereas if they
would have just said oh we got the best
player in the world we just keep doing
this
i'm not sure they would have got there
right but the coach phil jackson and the
team they had to adapt and so
you're saying why do we feel that pain
in rejection and how do we deal with
that
i think we feel that pain because we
look at a failure
right we look at it as a complete
definition of us
right we're looking at it as as there's
that famous statement of like you know
failure is an event not a person right
and i don't know who said it but it's
one of those statements that that really
clicks like failure is uh an event not a
person whereas we start thinking we are
the failure like we say i am a very late
i used to struggle a lot with
manifesting just the idea of it i would
watch videos on it and i didn't
understand what they were saying i
didn't i just didn't understand it uh
with this manifest in a lot of
attractions like what are they saying i
don't understand the words that are
coming out of your mouth and i would
rewind and watch again it's like i don't
get it i don't understand i don't i
don't understand and it seemed
weird silly
not good enough for me to just sit on a
couch and think about money coming into
your wallet or
whatever it was that you're trying to
manifest you got to go do something that
in law of attraction
you know action is at the end of
attraction like you got to go off and
and do the work if that's been you have
you been kind of struggling with
manifesting
or law of attraction you don't know how
it makes sense you rewind videos and and
it feels too woo-woo for you
let me uh let me let me explain it from
a different perspective and and maybe
it'll help at least this is what's
helped me the first thing that i
realized is
very scientific is from the reticular
activating systems it's part of your
brain that decides what to pay attention
to and what to not pay attention to
there there are so many things that are
happening right now all around you that
you are not paying attention to
most things your brain filters out your
the job of the reticular activating
system you can go look it up ras
is to filter out most things and only
filter in the things that you should
care about so for example
um you know what color are your socks
today what color is your underwear today
you know looking down this street and
you know i didn't know that there was a
pine tree here what are you paying
attention to as you look out the window
you're looking at the tree you're
looking at the
the sign here you're looking at the
driveway you're looking to cuddle the
sky you're looking at the house you look
at the what material that might be
you're not looking at anything again
it's too blurry you're still looking at
my face you're looking at my car you're
looking at the color of the headrest
you're looking at my outfit like what
are you paying attention to most things
you're ignoring
because there's no possible way to pay
attention to everything potentially the
dog just anna
hello good girl
right we're ignoring most things because
it wouldn't serve you it's just
impossible be information overload if
you feel like you're overloaded already
just imagine if you took in absolutely
everything so your eyes are bringing it
in and your brain is filtering out most
of it so what does your brain actually
pay attention to well the reticular
activating system
will choose to say okay you've set an
intention right i want to pay attention
to x and now all of a sudden you're
going to see that more often i i'm i
just bought a house so in that process
we started paying attention a lot more
to houses so one of the things i noticed
was the for sale sign here where i may
have not noticed that as much
in the past but because thinking house
boom now i'm paying attention to the for
sale sign you ever notice when you buy a
car you start seeing that car everywhere
right you're even thinking about buying
a car you're thinking about buying an x
you start seeing it on the street more
often
why that's your reticular activating
system basically saying
i want to pay attention to those things
so that car was still around right i
mean i i got this car we've got a
porsche
and now i see porsches more often those
porsches still existed they were they
were already there i just didn't notice
them before and now i notice them
because i have one right um
so whatever it is that you want
whatever it is that you're sending
intention towards it's not just sit on
your couch and meditate and imagine
money coming into your wallet or a new
car or new house or business growth or
you speaking on stage or whatever your
goals are right it's not just
sitting on it and visualizing it but
it's noticing it and the elements of it
in your environment that when you start
thinking about it
right we are what you we consistently
think about when you start thinking
about it you'll start seeing
opportunities around you that were
already there
you just filtered it out because you
didn't see how it connected
now your brain's starting to make those
connections does that make sense
reticular activating system you're
ignoring most things
but when you set intention on the thing
that matters to you you'll start seeing
it in your environment and opportunities
for that to happen a lot more often so
that's step number one reticular
activating system it's the science
number two is to trust your intuition
more one of the things that really
helped me back early on in my career was
i
judged myself too harshly for the ideas
that i came up with
and as soon as i came up with ideas like
oh you can't do that or i had to have
the perfect plan before i would ever
take any kind of action on it and you
know just later realize that
you can never plan all the way out
there's no way you know if you wait to
have the perfect plan by the time you
start actually executing the plan is
is dead it's over um and so you have to
trust in your ideas and so the thing
that
really helped me is
i believe that great ideas flow through
me
believe that great ideas flow through
you this is how you shortcut them your
brain that's designed to keep you safe
that's how you shortcut the brain out of
the equation
you came up with an idea as long as it's
in you're in a positive state of mind
you're trying to serve right it's not i
want to i want to go
you're in a jealous rage or you're angry
don't trust your ideas then
but when when you're positive and
optimistic and bold and courageous and
an idea comes to you trust that that's
the right idea for you just trust it
it's the right and then go do something
about it where normally what we do is we
overthink and we over plan and we over
prepare and then we lose the momentum
and then the next day and the next week
or the next month it's gone it's over
it's like oh i can't do that no that was
actually a great idea for you and it's
happened enough to me
uh
where those things have worked out
where i come up with an idea
and it doesn't make any sense
logically
but
i just decide to listen to it and do
something on it and it leads to
something amazing
the amount of times that that's happened
is
pretty overwhelming
and so when you have enough repetition
for me i had to see it you know i had to
see it enough times come up because i
wouldn't just believe it on faith i had
to see it happen enough times and you
could test it yourself what ideas in
your head what big idea that you want to
do even a small idea what's what's
flowing through your head when you're in
a positive state you know put on a happy
song
move around a little bit and then notice
your thoughts and where it's going and
what you want to create or who you want
to reach out to what you want to do like
what what thought comes to mind after
you're moving around and having some
positive energy that's probably the
right thing for you and just test it out
by doing something about it and maybe
that's a business idea maybe that's an
email you need to send maybe that's a
friend you need to reach out to
uh maybe that's an act of kindness that
you need to do whatever the thing is
that pops into your mind
trust those ideas and and you could be a
scientist like i'm i like data and i
like science and i like just i like
proving things
maybe i'm a skeptic i don't know but
in running those experiments i i proved
to myself that yeah great ideas
do flow through me and so the next time
i have a great idea i'm gonna go
and take action on it
so number one reticular activating
system
it's already in your environment you're
just ignoring it but if you put
attention towards it you start seeing it
like you notice a new car
when you buy your new car you see that
car everywhere and then number two is
trust that good ideas flow through you
number three is the one that i'm working
on that i'm i'm having
the hardest time with and i
i
believe it and i'm trying to
i'm in the process of getting better at
it is
when you're thinking about creating
something to talk to yourself in the
present moment
and this is something that
a lot of the manifestation a lot of
attraction people talk about but also
people like grant cardone
talk about it uh that is it's not just
the people who you'd associate with it
but other people have had a lot of
success where you're talking about
whatever thing is that you want that
it's that it's already happened
that it's not going to happen in the
future but that it's already happened
you know if your goal is to speak on
stage then you're
visualizing and you're telling yourself
i am
i am on stage i am speaking to
i am speaking to a million people or
that's that's that's a giant stadium
i am speaking to 70 000 people you know
i am i am the author of a best-selling
book uh i am like whatever your goal is
and
what i think the point of that is
is yes one to see yourself accomplishing
big things
uh two to not have a b so far away that
it lets you off the hook for taking
action but i think most importantly is
for you to feel what it feels like to be
that
and the more you feel like it feels like
to be that the more it actually becomes
true
if your goal is to speak on stage in
front of 5 000 people
and you actually
feel like you're doing it you can
visualize yourself being on stage and
doing it
the goal i think i'm still working
through this so one and two i've got
down three is my progress and my journey
so sharing with you
if you feel like you're doing it if you
are on stage and there's 5 000 people
clapping for you and cheering you you
just gave the best speech you know of
your life so far
and you feel what it feels like to walk
off that stage and
what a gift that you gave people
that the more comfortable you get with
that feeling
the more it's gonna be you
and the more that's gonna show up does
that make sense so whatever it is that
you are trying to accomplish
whoever it is that you're trying to be
whatever your big goals are
that
you imagine yourself already having done
it
and this is probably not something that
i would tell other people you know like
oh yeah i'm a i'm a you know i'm a
speaker in front of 70 000 people
because
because i haven't spoken at a stadium
that big
but
to yourself at least
to say it to see it to feel it to do it
if you're trying to heal yourself like
okay i am i am healthy
but look i've got i've got a belly or
i've got a you know whatever i'm i'm i
am healthy i am healthy and visualizing
yourself being healthy
because you want the feeling of what it
feels like to be healthy and the more
you feel like
you are healthy and you capture that
feeling the more frequently you're in
there the more likely it's going to show
up
so that's probably not the most
articulate way to share it and i'm still
working my way through it as well so as
i keep getting better and keep learning
i'll keep sharing with you
but i used to think like
manifestation law of attraction was way
out there stuff that that i judged and
that i didn't understand and that didn't
make any sense like just go off and take
action guys
and
with time and experience and exposure
and practice
um
using the reticular activating system to
notice things around me
by trusting that great ideas flow
through me and following through and
building momentum
and by
talking to myself in the present moment
as if i am that person that i want to
become so i can capture that feeling and
know what it feels like to be that
person
i've shifted and seen some pretty
amazing results in my life and business
and i hope it can work for you too i
think uh you know if we everything
starts with a thought i mean everything
that you do in your life you you have to
have a thought before you initiate an
action right
so if you believe that your thoughts
have something to do with your destiny
like any great leader in history
understands that
the first thing you have to do is you
have to decide are you going to be
defined by a vision of the future
or are you going to live by the memories
of the past so give you an example
most people wake up in the morning
and your brain is a record of the past
it's an artifact of everything you've
learned and experienced to this moment
right it's a it's a memory bank
so most people wake up in the morning
and they start thinking about their
problems and those problems are
connected to certain people and things
at certain times and places
and the moment they start start turning
on those circuits those memories are
actually causing them to think in the
past
every single one of those memories has
an emotion associated with them and
emotions are the end product of past
experiences so then the moment they
recall the event or the they recall some
problem in their life they start feeling
unhappy they start feeling discouraged
they start feeling anxious now thoughts
of the language of the brain and
feelings of the language of the body and
how you think and how you feel creates
your state of being so we could say then
most people's entire state of being when
they start their day is in the familiar
past well if you live in the familiar
past then it makes sense you're going to
create the predictable future so what
happens for most people is they get
stuck in their biology so think about
this
your body is your unconscious mind it
doesn't know the difference between an
experience in your life that creates an
emotion and an emotion that you can
create by thought alone so if you're
living by the same emotion every single
day and those emotions are influencing
your thoughts
and you can't think greater than how you
feel or feelings have become the means
of thinking you're thinking in the past
your lens of the future is going to be
colored by the past so you can't see
possibilities so most people like to
wait for crisis or disease or diagnosis
before they wake up enough to see well
the challenge is is that biology tends
to be redundant so
if you keep thinking the same thoughts
and those thoughts begin to fire certain
circuits in your brain the nerve cells
that fire together wire together so all
of a sudden you start getting hardwired
and those are the thoughts that you can
think the easiest at the same time those
thoughts produce chemicals called
emotions and the next thing you know
your body gets accustomed to living by
the same emotions and it could be guilt
it could be unhappiness it could be pain
but at least it's familiar to you at
least you can predict it so some people
would rather cling to the familiar than
take a chance in possibility so for most
people then they say well
i don't really see how my thoughts have
anything to do with my destiny well
that's because
95 of those thoughts are subconscious
programs right so you're not even
conscious that you think those thoughts
so the first step to change
is starting to think about what you've
been thinking about and change it and
and then when you begin to observe those
thoughts you're no longer the program
you're the consciousness observing just
simply by being an observer of your
thoughts right so so though so most
people though when they when you do that
when you decide to really take a look
it's like lighting a match in a dark
place
so you feel uncomfortable so it's easier
to turn on your tv it's easier to
play with your cell phone to distract
yourself from those feelings well when
you understand that change really
requires becoming uncomfortable to a
certain degree and that's normal that
you're leaving the known and you're
stepping into the unknown
then it begs the question what thoughts
do you want to fire and wire in your
brain because your attention on those
thoughts begins to reorganize circuitry
we mold the brain i don't think people
really realize we construct our lives
we build them from nothing we decide
what our goals are we decide in what way
to move we
decide who we're going to become and
what we're going to get
but it's a decision it's a process it
isn't something that somebody hands to
you
and so if you find that your life is a
misery understand that your life is an
exact reflection of your choices
and if you want a different life you
need only make a different choice
but i know right now many of you are
thinking but i don't know what way to go
i don't know what choice to make i don't
know what it is that i want to do
and as roy maurice keane said
i don't believe skill was or ever will
be the result of coaches it is a result
of a love affair between the child and
the ball
so ask yourself
what's that thing you love
and don't judge yourself if it was
something that you loved as a child that
people are telling you you couldn't
possibly make money and it's that part
of the equation that i want to break for
people i want you to understand stop
asking yourself what you can make a lot
of money at and start asking yourself
what would you enjoy what is that life
that you don't need to escape from what
is the life
that is your love what is the thing that
as a kid you did whether people wanted
you to or not what is the thing you
would sneak out at night to do because
you weren't going to be stopped from
doing it everybody has something like
that in their life some spark of
interest may be long dormant maybe that
they've pushed aside because they think
it's stupid
or maybe they failed once and they think
they're bad at it
even though they love it that sting of
the failure
has convinced them to stop pursuing it
but at the end of the day the only thing
that matters is what gives you that
energy
at the end of the day the thing that
matters is what fills you with joy at
the end of the day the only thing that
matters it's not success
and it's sure as hell isn't money
it's how you feel about yourself when
you're by yourself
it's the things that give you energy
it's what you think about yourself it's
how you react to the hard things it's
whether or not you push through
and when you push through when you
persevere when you go down the process
of taking the time to structure your
life
to build it into something that you want
it to be to build it into something that
you're proud of to become the person
that's capable of the things you want to
do that can first fall in love with
something and do it for the love of it
not worry about what other people think
if you hate your life i guarantee you
the thing is that you are trapped by
what other people think you don't want
to give it up because somebody will
think you're a failure you don't want to
give it up because it's a paycheck you
don't want to give it up because you're
scared
you're scared you don't know what you'll
do next
but imagine a world for a second where
all you thought about was what do you
love what do you enjoy in that moment it
doesn't matter if it changes from day to
day just what do you love
what fills you with joy what gives you
that energy at the end of the day the
only thing that we all have is right now
this moment
it's what you're experiencing
loving what you do how you spend your
time
that's the point of all of it
the point of life is that
in each transient moment that passes by
doing something that fills you with joy
nobody can give you that
you've got to build that life
so go out
figure out
what it is that you want to do
and brick by brick
have the courage to build that life
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
the 10 skills that are hard to learn but
will pay off forever check the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there so to help you on your journey
today i'm doing a video on the 10 skills
that are hard to learn but will pay off
forever and as always guys as you're
watching if you hear something that
really resonates with you